Secretary of State we are marking the
75th anniversary of the NHS being
founded in
1948. how do you reflect on that
Landmark well the NHS has changed
fundamentally if you look at the
advances in medicine you look at the
scale of the NHS so in 1948 it had a
budget of around 11 billion pounds it's
now over 180 billion it's had less than
150 000 staff it's now 1.6 million but
it's fundamental principles have
remained constant free at the point of
views the brilliant care from our
clinical staff
the importance that it has to the
country's sort of whole identity so I
think the NHS really is at the heart of
our national life and so whilst its
scale has changed its ability to save
lives and treat people has advanced
massively by the time it hits its 100th
anniversary in 2014 will we still have
an NHS funded by taxpayer is with
treatment free at the point of use
because subject Javid one of your
predecessors told me he thought that was
an unsustainable model what do you think
well we're committed to that and I think
there's real opportunities and we put
out an asthma on for example Artificial
Intelligence on early screening of lung
cancer but do you think it's sustainable
the model is sustainable free at the
point of view so you think that will
still be sustained in 20 years time
given all the Innovation the population
growth I think the NHS will need to
evolve much more onto prevention rather
than simply looking at treatment as we
have the pressure of a growing older
population also people living with
multiple conditions one in four and the
British public now have two or more
conditions and that's why we're focused
through our major condition strategy at
looking at treating people more
holistically let's look at the state of
the NHS today after 13 years of
conservative government have more people
ever been waiting for NHS treatment than
they are now well we can see the impacts
of the pandemic beds I mean if we take
I'm gonna let me
so let me give you a practical example
going into the pandemic there was around
1 300 patients waiting more than a year
for their operation at its peak that
increased uh to 410
000 but our plan on that is working last
summer we cleared uh virtually
eliminated the entire two-year wait so
we cleared over 90 percent of the
18-month weights and contrast that weird
labor run Wales where I haven't cleared
those uh there's a single okay I'm going
to have to oh wait so no it's only fair
it's a fair challenge but it's also
fantastic time to answer that okay so so
but record weightless is okay for people
to wait in a a e for over four hours no
we don't want people waiting that's why
we have a recovery plan it's why we're
investing more there's opportunities
through that plan to embrace technology
things like virtual Wards are hugely
important we're putting more into social
care it was the centerpiece or the Alton
statement but so to say the point I'm
making is record waiting lists uh 26 of
everyone attended an a be waiting more
than four hours in May 1.2 million
people wait and see a GP waiting over a
month in April ambulances heart attack
straight victims they should be seen
within 18 minutes that's a Target the
average in April 32 minutes on average
to get patients with conditions like
that you've talked a lot about the
Innovation but what what people see as
an NHS that's failing them well the NHS
is under pressure but your charges these
values down to the conservative
government let me pick up your exact
figures you say about four of our
weights in a e the labor run NHS in
Wales hasn't met it's for our a e Target
since 2009 so if your charges this is a
political thing this is now to the
government running the NHS in England
that doesn't work when you look at the
record of the NHS so you think it is the
impact of the pandemic well I think we
can see in the numbers a dramatic shift
in terms of operational performance as a
result
the Prime Minister knew when you talk
about the problems in the NHS you always
blame it on the pandemic and actually if
you look at the record from 2010
deficits in NHS trusts became wides for
2014 the NHS failed to kick he waiting
time Targets in 2014 and the following
years that's the king's fund again from
April 2023 so in 2014 six years before
covid weighting targets would be missed
Secretary of State I mean are you saying
that this is a combination of austerity
followed by cuts and then the pandemic
that has put the NHS in the crisis it's
now in no firstly I'm saying the
pandemic has had a massive impact not
just on the NHS in England but on the
NHS in Wales in Scotland and actually
when I talked with my counterparts on
Healthcare Systems across the globe and
you can see that in the graphs a very
sharp impact in terms of operational
performance there's other factors that
also create challenges we have an older
population waiting targets with not
after 2020 but between 2010 and 2020
look let's take what we have let's take
elective treatment 92 of people waiting
for elective treatment that's cataract
surgery need Replacements seen within 18
weeks from their referral when was that
Target last met so again let's you know
what I mean I've got your question but
no my point is do you know when it's
lost let's put it in context so we have
a plan in terms of elective recovery
that plan is working we cleared the
two-year waits in the summer we cleared
over 90 of the 18-month weights by the
end of March
but it's not missed that Target was
being missed in September 2015. my point
is it's not Avid it's problems before
covid no one is saying there weren't any
challenges before the pandemic indeed
why the then prime minister prime
minister May brought forward a long-term
Platinum was a recognition that there
were areas as I said
as an example in the long term plan I've
given one on Mental Health let me give
you a different example we increased uh
then uh Health secretary now Chancellor
increased medical undergraduate places
by 25 through the long-term plan a very
significant expansion you acknowledge
that between 2010 and up to Teresa may
being prime minister targets were missed
that a long-term plan comes in then we
have the pandemic targets amidst another
long-term plan comes in a e for our
targets were last met in 2015 Cancer
Care targets last May in 2015.
do you see the point I'm making here yes
and at the point I'm making is things
like the the four hour Anna Target in
Wales hasn't been met since 2009 and so
yes of course before the pandemic so
that makes it okay because well your
charge was this is down to well you're
investment running the NHS England which
serves millions and millions of us what
I'm trying to get to section of state
and for the viewers watching is people
love the NHS it's a national treasure
they care about it passionately when I'm
trying to make the point to is just for
you to be straight with people about
austerity caused problems before covid
has exacerbated that those problems and
you don't seem to acknowledge that this
is partly on the conservative government
not just after the pandemic but the way
it was run for the past 13 years well
what I'm saying is that we're always
disagree with that you don't think they
were funding Cuts what I'm saying is we
have invested consistently in the NH as
I pointed to point this stuff out from
the king's concert that's exactly the
opposite point to a given concrete
examples a 25 increase for example in
the number of doctors being trained the
extra investment into areas like mental
health okay this is from the king's
health fund long-term improvements in
population Health I've installed or went
into reverse after 2010 the coalition
government and the success conservative
government since then have failed to
hear heed the warning size of
deteriorating performance that's your
record a decade before covid that's your
record I think of for example that the
patients I met on Monday where in one of
the most deprived areas of the country
we were picking up lung cancer at late
in four in five cases and now we're
picking lung cancer okay in four cases
so we are making significant progress
and I think as we Mark the scientific
you're absolutely right Beth public
usually value the NHS I hugely value
this IMI family use the NHS as you do
and that is why we're making this record
investment in the workforce of the NHS
it's a genuinely historic 10 minutes
and that's a sign of this government's
commitment the public satisfaction chart
that I've dug out shows public
satisfaction plummeting in the NHS in
1997 18 years after a conservative
government and now in 2023 after 13
years of conservative government it's
now back at a record high isn't the
truth that the public think that you
have failed them on the NHS well the
truth is
the truth is we have the biggest ever
investment in the NHS estate through
over 20 billion pounds going into our
new hospitals program we have a historic
investment we have a historic investment
if you let me answer the questions
you're not acknowledging my questions we
are investing record sums in the NHS
estate where we're investing in record
sums in the workforce were also being
Innovative and taking lessons out of
covid around our use of artificial
intelligence and Tech but at no point
have you acknowledged that funding Cuts
hit waiting lists up to 2020 and that
has been exacerbated by the pandemic and
you might not want to say that to me for
political reasons but I think people who
use the NHS feel it and then they feel
that you're not acknowledging their
truth what I've acknowledged is there
were pressure on waiting times going
into the pandemic because we have an
older population
but also your challenge in terms of the
performance now that has been shaped
significantly by the pandemic and that
is in line with other systems across the
UK and across the world but we're
investing in our Workforce in our NHS of
State in the latest technology that is
how we build a sustainable NHS for the
future so keep the faith is your message
to the public yes okay Secretary State
thank you so much for your time
appreciate it thank you